[Music]
ragnarok the fabled end of the world
when Giants monsters and Norse gods
battle for the future the gods were
winning handily until the great serpent
jörmungandr emerged it swallowed
Valhalla contorted itself across the
land and then merged into one continuous
body with no head and no tail as it
begins to digest Valhalla an exhausted
Odin explains that he has just enough
power to strike the creature with one
final bolt of lightning if you magnify
his blasts with your fabled hammer
Mjolnir it should pierce the massive
serpent you'll run with super speed
along the Serpent's body when you hold
your hammer high Odin will strike it
with lightning and split your man gander
open at that point then you'll need to
continue running along its body until
every part of it is destroyed
you can't run over the same section
twice or you'll fall into the already
blasted part of the snake but you can
make multiple passes through points
where the creature intersects its own
body if you leave any portion UNH's apt
Norman Gander will magically regenerate
Odin's last power will be spent and
Valhalla will fall forever what path can
you take to destroy the serpent
one powerful way to solve problems is to
simplify and in this case we can focus
our attention on the two things that are
important for our path intersections and
the stretches of snake between them or
as they're referred to in graph theory
nodes and edges the edges are important
because they're what we need to travel
and the nodes matter because they
connect the edges and are where we may
need to make choices as we run from edge
to edge this simplification into nodes
and edges leaves us with a ubiquitous
and important mathematical object known
as a graph or network we just need to
figure out how to travel what
mathematicians call an oil Arian path
which traces every edge exactly once
instead of looking at the path as a
whole let's zoom in on a single node
during some moment in your run you'll
enter that node and then exit it that
takes care of two edges if you enter
again you'll need to exit again - which
requires another pair of edges so every
point along your path will have edges
that come in pairs one edge in each pair
will function as entrance the other has
exit and that means that the number of
edges coming out of every node must be
even there are just two exceptions the
start and end points where you can exit
without entering or vice versa if we
look at the network formed by the
serpent again and number how many edges
emerge from each node a pattern jumps
out that fits what we just saw every
node has an even number of edges
emerging from it except two so one of
these must be the start of your route
and the other the end interestingly
enough any connected network that has
exactly two nodes with an odd number of
edges will also contain an Euler Ian
path the same is true if there are no
nodes with an odd number of edges in
that case the path starts and
in the same spot so knowing that let's
return to our full graph we can begin by
taking care of this edge here now we can
zigzag back and forth across the whole
snake until we reach the end and that's
just one solution it helps to be
systematic but you're likely to happen
upon many others once you know where to
begin and end your run you hold your
hammer high at the opportune moment and
Odin sends the world saving surge of
lightning at you then you run like
you've never run before if you can pull
this off
surely nothing could stop the might of
the Norse gods and if something like
that were out there slouching its way
towards you
well that would be a story for another
day fortunately you can prepare for that
fateful day by using brilliant brilliant
is a problem-solving based platform that
has over 60 courses in math science and
computer science its course library will
let you brush up on mathematical
fundamentals or forge ahead into
subjects you've never studied before
visit brilliant org slash ted-ed
to check it out and the first eight
hundred thirty three of you to visit
using that link will receive 20% off the
annual premium subscription fee
[Music]